so alright that's fine now let's have a
think about what this care not what this
can yield for us okay for example let's
come down to a point like heal okay now
I won't say anything yet about the angle
tell me the coordinates of that point
that's gonna be one zero one zero right
but we just defined those two numbers
one and zero as the cosine and the sine
of the angle related to this point right
so one is the college of an angle and
zero is the sine of an angle okay the
question is what angle corresponds to
this point and they the answer is the
angle is zero degrees right because I'm
measuring from the x-axis and I'm on the
x-axis right so that means that cause
all 0 degrees is 1 and sine of zero
degrees is zero okay I can keep going
now you see now I've got I've got
answers to these boundaries right come
up to the top what are the coordinates
at this point zero what right again
what's the angle that corresponds to
that point on the circle answer
90 degrees right so what this really
tells me is that that's cos 90 coz of 90
degrees is zero and sine of 90 degrees
is 1 okay can you see what's happening
here we have breaking out of the
triangle right I can now work with
angles that I see you vary the
contouring a triangle with zero degrees
in it and I can do triangles which have
you know only acute angles but I can do
nine yeah thanks I thank you okay so I
have some insights here right let's keep
going around and see what happens I'm
still up here right let's draw an angle
like say
okay now this time not because it's a
point off in the middle of like wherever
okay I don't know exactly what values
are equal to so I'm gonna go this time
from the point of view of the angle okay
they go so remember the angle this theta
that we're talking about starts from the
positive x-axis I have to say positive
constants this side not this side of the
negative x-axis based upon each side and
then I go anti-clockwise right so this
angle another country is going to be a
reflex angle okay that's so far I guess
I I map used Ron Porter okay so what
angle should I choose for the sake of my
illustration here I'm gonna make that
120 degrees when you're trading routes
now I want to know if what cause of 120
and sine of 120 are equal to and it's
like this triangle he kind of stopped
right but on the unit circle I can work
this out right here's how I'm gonna do
it I went up pop down another vertical
line there and make a triangle and the
great thing about this is if I have 120
degrees
here because the x-axis is a straight
line right I can know what this angle
inside the triangle is right it's 60
okay now if I know that that's 60 I also
know what the length of the hypotenuse
is it's one okay so now I can work out
what this side is which will give you
the cosine and what that this side is
which will give me the sign what ratio
do I choose I choose cause I choose it
for two reasons number one because it's
adjacent by hypotenuse but number two
because I'm now redefining Clause is the
x-coordinate right so it's that forever
okay so I can say this side here should
be well cause of 60 will be this on one
right so cuz of 60 is just that side
cause of 60 hold on I know what cuz of
60 is don't write it's cause of 61 0 60
is sine 30 which is enough okay
in fact you can see I've drawn my
triangle pretty well right cuz look it's
about half way that's right we'll get to
that okay so I've got this side down
because of 60 now I'll work out this
side well it's the other one isn't it so
it's going to be sine 60 which is okay
that's better
alright so now what do I say I want to
know the coordinates of this thing
okay what's the x-coordinate it's minus
1/2 because I'm on the left hand side of
the Cartesian plane right and the
y-coordinate well it's above that's fine
that's root 3 on 2 okay so now see this
is this is brilliant right
this is not a ratio minus 1/2 that
doesn't make sense
how where are you wearing your triangle
is your - right and the answer is well
under 20 on I'm not slide that try and
Lena ok but I have a meaning for it
because the unit circle gives me a
meaning let's quickly go down to here
let's come down here
now if I'm looking for Tigers my
diagrams getting pretty busy but if I
would you pick out a point there okay
right away you should be able to tell me
the sign of the x corner and the sign of
the Y chord
they're both gonna be right because look
I'm negative x and I'm negative Y does
that make sense okay now let's take that
idea let's take that idea because this
is where I'm one of his common
abbreviations I want to think about sine
cos and tan in each of these quadrants
sine kazantip
now remember
that's why the truth okay think about
this with me remember the cosine is the
x value right so let's just do that for
the whole diagram okay for cosine right
over this side of the diagram is cosine
positive or negative it's positive isn't
it because on this side all the x's are
positive right whatever number you pick
the exo a positive so close will be
positive here and it will be positive
here Sam make sense you cross over all
these values are negative right so close
is negative here because it's negative
you can play the same game doing sign
except above the axis sine is positive
positive positive and below the axis
sine is negative okay now 10 we said was
the ratio between sine and cos that's
what's one divided by the other so if I
divide two positive numbers
what will the sine the ratio be it's up
positive okay if I divide it's I know
cause isn't it a positive I'm up by a
negative number
what will the sign be negative if I
divide two negative numbers positive and
lastly this is the same as over there
that'll be negative okay now step back
have a look at what we've determined
over here in the first quadrant it's the
first quadrant because that's where you
start counting okay in the first
quadrant all three of our main trig
ratios such an eccentric functions
they're all all a for all positive okay
as I go around the unit circle two
different quadrants I only ever have one
ratio that remains positive right
over here were positive s for sign down
here chief
and then over here see for cause so some
of you have heard this as the acronym
starting from the first quadrant a s T C
which depending on who you ask
stands for o station is essential or if
I'd sugar a coffee or if you were not
enough in her nose at my my old school
down the road there was a comprehensive
school which didn't quite have as good
an academic reputation as dangerous sir
there was a teacher who's very fond of
saying all students to Cumberland
because that's where you go if you don't
understand if you are know if a
basically here's another one which is um
I don't know it's this isn't a classes
but he says all students take cocaine so
yeah obviously you know you a junior
student so he gave me the PG version so
okay now here's the thing here's the
thing that okay um this acronym this
acronym I really dislike this happening
I don't like it the reason why is
because not obviously you guys but many
people learn it HTC and it masks
understanding what's really going on
right all that's really going on is look
like summarize we pulled up here because
X is positive here and Y is positive
here
okay X is negative and Y is pleasant so
that's why the corresponding trig
functions who have the same science
that's really what's going on by all
means use all stapes station is to
central as a crush okay to help you
remember to help you evaluate things
okay but please please please
Lou is actually going on it's just about
X's and Y's
yeah sine cosine of 120 degrees is
negative 1/2 and if I come down to here
right for instance if I said sine of any
angle between 180 degrees and 270
degrees all the cosines and sines of all
those angles will be negative okay yeah
yeah go ahead you chuck in I mean would
be one we worked out just now was cause
of 120 and it'll tell you - aha
now by the way it's not that this thing
is smart it's just that this thing has
been told to do this right so it gives
you a right